fiebre por Putin en Moscú miles de rusos
llenaron el estadio luz Niki por el día
de los defensores de la patria con
bandera sondeando y ovaciones al
mandatario expresaron el apoyo a su
presidente la que denominan operación
militar especial contra Ucrania a
exaltado la figura de poder de Putin y
sus seguidores se sienten más Unidos a
él que nunca
el discurso de ayer fue muy interesante
tuvo un efecto muy tranquilizador
escuchas al presidente y te calmas tiene
un efecto terapéutico le escuchas y
piensas que todo irá bien que vamos por
el buen camino creo que la gente lo
necesita ahora sentir la ayuda y el
apoyo de un padre es como un padre para
nosotros
Vladimir Putin es una figura popular
dentro de Rusia pero en los últimos años
también ha generado polarización dentro
de los ciudadanos las detenciones de sus
opositores han causado que muchos
ciudadanos deseen un cambio en la escena
política del país los trabajadores son
otro frente donde Putin ha perdido apoyo
ya que las reformas impulsadas por su
gobierno son impopulares dentro del
gremio
creo que el voto es solo un espectáculo
sirve más para que Putin demuestre que
mira la gente que me apoye y todavía me
necesitan pero en realidad la mayoría de
la gente está en su contra y solo tiene
miedo de hablar
según encuestas de la ong elevada Center
la popularidad de Putin se había
mantenido por encima del 80% hasta
agosto del 2022 pero las cifras bajaron
a 77% a raíz de las muertes de efectivo
rusos en Ucrania